people that are able to afford a
floating playground as I call it costing
anything from 30 million pounds up to
100 million pounds these are people that
are going to want things done their way
we've got three decks and I'm going to
take you around our vest enough money is
the founder of bespoke Bureau which
trains staff for the world's most
expensive yachts these girls are the
latest batch of recruits but we can't
show you their faces most have signed
privacy agreements with their employers
in the super yacht industries of upmost
importance that the staff are very very
discreet anything they hear or see just
stays with them we also get them to sign
a very strict confidentiality agreement
which means that they'll end up in court
should they spill any beans the
mega-wealthy
value their privacy and are prepared to
pay their crew handsomely Sarah says
hard-working recruits can expect to
start on more than $60,000 often
tax-free it is lucrative but you mustn't
forget that they work really really hard
and they do earn them their money and
they work very long hours so although it
looks so from an outsider's point of
view like a very luxury job these girls
and boys work very very hard when
money's not an issue and a small army
are on hand at all times requests can
get outlandish dinner at 4:00 a.m.
late-night parties demanding guests
superyacht workers often get little
sleep but what exactly goes on on board
is kept close to the chest the first
rule of anybody working in that
marketplace is you don't talk about it
and I would never disclose what I know
and have they going to do fire engine
blasts Andrews a professional battler
but he won't say who he's worked for
after a week of training it's graduation
time most of these girls are heading
back to their yachts in time for the
summer season long hours late nights and
a chance to make some big money
Angus Bennett blue beau London